For the last like 50 or 60 years,
space has mostly been dominated
by a handful of governments.
It took government money
to get a rocket up,
to build a satellite.
Around sort of 2008, the
launch of this Falcon 1 rocket,
made by SpaceX, that marked the first time
we had billionaires who
had some success in space.
We have lift off.
And now we're at this
really interesting moment
in time where I think pretty
much inspired by this example,
everybody decided they
could do space as well
and could take a crack at these things
that people have been dreaming
about for almost a century.
We've gone from
governments to billionaires
to now all this private
money, venture capitalists,
just regular old millionaires
flooding in to space
and funding all kinds of projects.
As space becomes more accessible
to private enterprise,
many companies are hoping
to make it not just
possible but affordable
to put objects into orbit.
Now, a rocket startup called Astra is
on the verge of launching rockets
at a fraction of the
cost of its competitors,
potentially opening up a new era
in the technology and business of space.
As I look 50 years into the future,
I see a platform emerging in space
and right above that thin
blue line, I see competition,
I see ecosystems that are
global, I see standards emerging
and I see a really exciting opportunity
for a trillion plus
dollar economy to form.
My name's Chris Kemp, I'm the founder,
chairman and CEO of Astra and
we're in our rocket factory,
located just across the Bay Bridge
from San Francisco in Alameda, California.
And I think that Astra is really
offering a very unique service.
No one can go anywhere on earth
and put something anywhere in space
in a few days with a few people.
We started talking
about basically the idea
of building a rocket factory
from the very beginning
and this idea was based on the principle
that if you make a lot of something,
the cost comes down a lot
so we're building Hondas not Ferraris.
We don't use any of the exotic materials,
carbon fiber composites, 3D printing,
that a lot of other companies
like to talk a lot about.
They're actually very expensive
and they're very hard to scale
so we're building these
rockets out of aluminum
so we're bending, we're
welding, we're fastening,
we're stamping, we're machining aluminum
but our thesis was that
if you could build rockets
like an aircraft or an automobile,
we could really bring the economics
in line with some of these larger rockets.
Astra's entering
into a crowded and well-funded space.
SpaceX is the clear
leader with its Falcon 9,
Falcon Heavy and Falcon
Super Heavy rockets.
Another front runner is New
Zealand based Rocket Lab
with their Electron and Neutron rockets.
Astra has announced two different models,
one small, one big and says
both will be much faster
and cheaper to build than
those of its competitors.
For like 100 years, people
in the United States,
Germany, Russia have
been trying to build one
of these small liquid fueled rockets.
The first private company
to really pull it off was SpaceX in 2008.
It took SpaceX seven
years to go from nothing
to getting this first rocket up.
Astra's whole goal really was to try
and shrink that time as much as possible
and to develop and manufacture this type
of rocket faster than
any company in history.
Over the next few years
here at this facility,
we'll be increasing the
production rate of rockets
from monthly this year to
weekly in 2023 to bi-weekly
in 2024 to a full daily
production rate in 2025
and by launching a rocket a day,
we'll be able to bring
the price point down
to about a half a million dollars
and we'll be selling launches
for a few million dollars that can deliver
between three and 500
kilograms to low-earth orbit.
Astra's ambition was born
from the massive demand for
getting small satellites
into low earth orbit.
Startups are lining up to
hitch rides on bigger rockets,
often waiting months or
years for their turn.
Well, about five years ago,
one of my best friends started Planet,
which was the pioneer in
building small satellites
and they were having some
real trouble getting to space.
After spending a few months,
meeting a bunch of the
other rocket companies,
it was pretty clear that
he needed to be able
to get from anywhere on
earth to anywhere in space
on his schedule, not the
schedule of some large satellite.
If you're a small satellite company
and you want to get on a SpaceX rocket,
the going rate for a SpaceX launch
is about $60 million
and there's gonna be one
or two very large satellites
that are on that rocket
and they're really the primary payload.
All these startups want to be these,
what they call secondary payloads.
They're sort of attached
around the big satellites
and so you're paying almost to be
like a second class
citizen on this rocket.
The large satellites, the
people that are really paying
for the bulk of the launch,
they get deposited exactly
in the orbit that they want.
Then the secondary
satellites get dropped off
and usually they have to
use really small thrusters
on the satellites then to
kind of push themselves
into their desired orbit.
There's not as many guarantees
that you're going to end
up in the right spot.
Companies like Planet Labs are aiming
to dispatch many tiny
satellites all around the globe
in what's called a constellation.
The satellites can do
various computational tasks
using data from all over the earth
and since they're tiny and
sit in low earth orbit,
they just burn up in the atmosphere
after a while, rather than contributing
to the growing problem of space debris.
As more and more companies try
to build systems like this,
the need for easy access to space
is becoming greater and greater.
That's where Astra comes in.
The idea with the small rockets is
that you're getting
your own ride to space.
It's taking your satellite
to exactly the orbit you want
and even more than that, you're
not having to wait months
and months and months to
find space on a launch.
The whole idea here with
something like Astra
is you hop on a website,
you book a rocket launch,
you send them your satellite and hopefully
in a couple of weeks, your
satellite's up in orbit
so we've never seen anything
like this sort of access to space
and the pace at which you
could fly something into space
In much the same way,
Amazon has big warehouses
and trucks that pull up.
You wouldn't land an Airbus 380
on Market Street and
deliver a package to me.
A little sprinter van pulls up
and someone walks up
and delivers a package.
Just look back at the last 10 years.
We've seen almost 400
companies now formed,
solving all sorts of really
interesting problems,
looking at the earth, looking
at how crops are growing,
looking at where we're fishing oceans,
looking at how to prevent
things like coral reefs
being overheated in the oceans
and understanding weather patterns.
I can't imagine all the applications.
While private space flight
is becoming an increasingly crowded field.
The success rate is still extremely low.
More than 20 rocket
startups have now failed
and there are at least 80 others
currently trying to get off the ground.
Only two private companies,
SpaceX and Rocket Lab,
are flying regular missions to space
and Astra could be on the
verge of becoming the third.
So Astra's been at it for
about four or five years.
They've done really well in many senses.
They actually got to Alaska
and did their first launch
in about two years, which was a record.
Rocket launch in Kodiak,
Alaska, pretty cool.
The downside of that launch
was that the rocket blew up.
Whoa.
It took 'em about a couple more tries
and then just at the end of last year,
they had really what was,
for all intents and purposes,
a tremendous success,
their rocket got like just
to the edge of low earth
orbit within really a few feet
and so we know now that
their rocket works.
The company plans
to launch another rocket later this year
as they continue to inch towards
making commercial flights.
Eventually, they hope to launch
a rocket every single day
which could lead to an
exponential increase
in the number of satellites in orbit.
I mean, we're at this
super interesting time
that I don't think most people
are paying attention to,
which is that at the start of this year,
there are probably about
2200 satellites roughly
orbiting the earth.
If you look at the launch manifests
of the various rocket
and satellite companies,
that number is supposed
to go to about 50,000
to a 100,000 satellites in
the next five to 10 years.
This is the next great technology story,
the next great computing
infrastructure story
is what's going to happen
right above our heads
and so the next few
years are going to bring
with them this unbelievable
frenetic amount of activity,
both from the rocket companies
and the satellite companies,
and really all the global powers kind of
understanding the new rules of engagement
that go in to this era when governments
do not control this real
estate that had been
the most prized, expensive
real estate there is.
Now, just about anyone with
a decent amount of money
and a decent amount of
brains can get to space
and do something interesting there.
Our customers will be able to go
from a concept to a constellation
to really helping improve life on earth
in months instead of many years
and that's really our purpose
and I think over the next few years,
you'll see us really make
it easier to allow space
to be a platform for
entrepreneurs across the world.